dry Sidle and and hurt him in that play
and it was a part of it he finishes here
on that's that razor thin playing on the
edge and Bunting looking away but got
into that zone and it's it's the elbow
follow into the head that I'm sure was
the sticking point move contracts out
that limits your ability to make a trade
and more cider doing his s defensively
been much more physical this year than a
year ago trips the Puck from thinking
the puck
there but he never has the
puck like that more than anything look
shoulders tucked in elbows down hits
fine Puck's not there it's interference
great patience as he enters the
offensive zone the puck eventually gets
towards that r with a piece of it and
there's pzy with a big hit on Brady Shay
as those two Collide the referee also is
going to get contact comes a break train
running ra atam and gave him everything
he had right there on a big hit that
obviously sent him look at watch the
side of the body and the torque and the
oh boy that's going to leave a mark as
you watch him carry it right through the
middle
and that's a big
Collision well that's it's a hard
hit I don't I don't know if it makes
contact Zone Zone spurge into to
Middleton he deflects it out to Center
Hartman One Touch for capriso and then
there's a collision at Center Ice
Hartman gets
jumped Hardman collided with elers at
Center ice it looked
inadvertent and then he is jumped from
behind forward in front Puck is still
loose londell is there and a penalty
coming up and a massive hit by goodus at
the echo of that whistle coming on
lomber for a
sck he's got test the early like O'Brien
has goneo and here's the hit that is a
monster hit that's the best hit we've
seen all year he separated here well
here's the hit where March's just trying
to pick up the puck a little bit behind
him and doesn't see Susi stepping up and
just right in the chest to level
marchment yeah good clean hit to start
the game steps
up
to
by there comes again and
he's yeah he's his timing on those types
of hits as as we
know is as good as anybody head down all
the way and there you see him again his
that just goes through Manson returning
after missing 31
games
his Avalanche with a 3-1 lead on the
Minnesota
Wild corner on Lowry this is a guy who
stuck up for every guy in that Minnesota
game with five minutes left you know
obviously you want the Hawks to get more
chances as tenori lights up Paul cter
from his physical play including this
monster hit completely clean just going
to Swerve come right back into the play
and this is the result right there
get steps in and he just throws
everything he's got at him right there
team Oher oh blasted by trouba and not
getting up another one of those big hits
by
trouba able to lift it out of the Zone
conre after itre against tro oh oh Big H
and once again troa challenge This Time
by
Dubay